The really important thing here is that
policy iteration does not get stuck in
the local optimum.
That is to say if there's any way to
improve it will actually improve.
It won't get stuck before.
So, the important step in the proof for
that is actually back one slide when
we talked about value non deprovement or
what I called value improvement.
So I went back a slide so
we could look at this together.
So, this is the claim that I'm making,
Charles.
If it's the case that pi 1 is optimal,
than the greedy policy
pi 2 with respect to the fixed point
of pie 1, is going to be the same.
We're actually going to be
stuck at the fixed point.
Because that's the whole
thing about a fixed point.
But if it's not, if it's not then there
has to be at least one state someplace
where this value non-deprovement
is actually value improvement,
like strict value improvement for
some state.
Like that.
>> I see.
So what's really going on here is
we should be more precise, maybe,
about what value improvement really
means, what value non-deprovement means.
>> Okay.
>> We're talking about it.
Every time we talk about it, we talk
about it in terms of one value function
better than another so
it's easy to think of it that way.
But if that were the case,
then I could have sort of cycles, right,
where You know I have two states where I
keep on each iteration swapping back and
forth, which one is better
than the other, and
you'd still have domination
in both cases, right?
Does that make sense, what I just said?
>> Wait, no, because domination
is point wise, it's state wise.
>> Yes it is statewise, but
imagine I had two states,
let's call them S1 and S2.
And let's say for one particular value
function, if I were going to compare,
let's say Q1 and Q2 or V1 and
V2, going to compare V1 and V2.
It turns out that in S1 V1
is greater than it is in V2.
So just making up some numbers.
Right in the other
case they're the same.
>> The same.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Then I could apply
an operator to both of them.
It would also be the case, so
here V1 dominates V2, right?
>> Right.
>> So
here's another set of numbers I could
write down where V1 still dominates V2.
>> Okay.
>> So rewrite the S1 and
S2 again underneath.
>> All right, so V1 still dominates V2.
>> Right, so V1 still dominates V2
if I just swap the two rows around.
And, so if you weren't thinking
carefully about what value improvement
or value non-deprovement meant, you
would think that you could just go back
and forth between these two different
values where 10, 6 and 3, 3, those
rows sort of swap, because in both cases
you're still getting V1 dominating V2.
But it's actually the case that the way
this value improvement works, is that
it's true not just for the overall value
functions, it's true at every state.
>> Oh I see, yes it can't be the case
that we go from V 1 S 1 being ten,
to V 1 S 1 being three,
because it's actually non-deproving.
>> Right.
>> In other words, we can't go down,
we can stay the same but
we can't go down.
>> Right, so the statement has to
be the case for all the states,
as well as the overall set of states.
So once V1 is better
than V2 in some state,
it basically has to stay that way.
>> Got it.
>> So
this keeps us from cycling back and
forth.
And this is what keeps us
from getting locally stuck.
That's my claim.
>> Okay.
All right so
local stuckness doesn't happen.
And in particular we get strict value
improvement in at least one state
if we haven't actually reached
the fix point yet, and
therefore each time we go through
policy iteration it's actually getting
better until it can't
get better anymore.
So one other interesting thing to point
out, is that the number of policies,
each time that we go through
an iteration of policy iteration.
We have a new deterministic policy.
There's just a finite number of them,
therefore; at some point we exhaust
the set of possible
improvements that we can make.
And we have to have found
the optimal policy.
>> You know what that reminds me of?
>> Yeah
>> Oh
so
>> Okay.
>> Reminds me of the proof we had for
YK means how to convert
>> Oh, yes, yes, yes.
It's exactly the same argument.
When we talked about
k-means in the other class,
we talked about how there's a finite
set of assignments that can be made and
each time you do
an iteration of k-means,
we get either the same assignment or
one that has a better score and
therefore, we're going to find
the one with the best score.
>> Well, we're going to find a one
that doesn't change anymore.
But the difference
between k-means proof and
this, is that you could get
stuck in a local optimum.
>> In K-means.
>> K-means, but here you can.
And I think the big difference is that
you basically, it's statement of value
non-deprovement is, at every single
point, every single state, in this case.
Where as with K-means,
that wasn't necessarily the case.
Okay, super.
So do you feel like your
grokking policy iteration now?
>> Yeah, in particular I'm grokking
that it actually kind of has to work.
That's sort of cool.
>> Cool, I think we can sum up then.
>> Let's sum up.
I like summing up.